Reportage : Mirna Djukic.
- De l'Allemagne
jusqu'au Canada,
les appels pour améliorer f f fs
et le respect des droits
humains en Iran résonnaient
particulièrement fort ce samedit
le 75e anniversaire
de la Déclaration
des droits de la personne.
dont la mort a catalyséle soulèe
en septembre, se mélangeait
cette fois à un autre.
- Mohsen Shekari!
- Mohsen Shekari
un jeune homme de 23 ans,
a été pendu ce jeudi pour
un paramilitaire en septembre.
C'est la pmièmière exécution
depuis le début du soulèvement.
ANGELO MINGARELLI, manifestant
c'est que ça continue.
Les écécutions vont continuer.
- Les politologues et
organisations humanitaires
d'une quarantaine demanifestantt
qui pourraient très bientôt
subir le même sort.lolololololoe
Chaire Raoul-Dandurand
- C'est une manière
pour l'État iranien
de donner un message faiaiaiaia.
C'est vraiment... vous voyez,
la peine de mort et ce type
d'exécution sont un outil
de terreur, d'ine e e e e e e ee
du régime iranien pour
faire taire les dissidents,
- Certains individus
vont avoir... peur, demain,
de sortir. Ne serait-ce que
sortir de chez eux parioioioioit
même pas de participer
à une manifestation. Il y a
un sentiment d'insécurité,
il y a un enviros s s s s s s s.
- Mais c'est un couteau
à deux tranchants.
- L'ensemble du pays est indigné
parce que, si  e e e e e e e e r
les enfants d'un pays.
Mahsa Amini avait 22 ans,
Mohsen a 23 ans. On a eu même
des cas beaucoup plus jeunes.
a perdu la vie. Ce type de
pratique va contbubuer à nourrir
le sentiment de frustration,
d'indignation, de colère.
et de mon entourage, ça ne nous
fera pas taire", ajoute
cette politologue iranienne.atan
prendra le dessus sur la peurpo.
Ici Mirna Djuki